[Music]
pay tributes I'm Meg McCarthy from
Fandango movie clips with the top 5
things to know before seeing Mockingjay
part 1
first things first district 13 exists
who knew it was rebuilt as a secret
undercover fully functioning society to
house the new rebellion and nuclear
bombs
lots of nuclear bombs president snow has
been lying to us this whole time
never trust a man who can look in two
directions at once
number two Katniss is in love with two
dudes two hot guys cry me a river'
catnip the big joke is she wasn't even
looking for love but she can't bring
herself to swipe left on either one of
these perfect matches
Gale is way hotter but he's a bit
temperamental and he's always rattling
on about the capital and injustice on
the other hand Peeta always says the
right thing he is a good moral compass
he Katniss are already engaged but he
makes cakes for a living
deal-breaker oh maybe three a lot of
tributes survive the Quarter Quell Peeta
has been captured by the Capitol we
aren't sure if he's been brainwashed or
he just adores wearing fancy clothes and
that's why he's shown with snow on TV
sexy shirtless Finnick was only
pretending to like sugar cubes he's
really part of the rebellion remember
who the real enemy is
Johanna Mason is alive but snows got her
locked up BT is kicking it with the
rebels and I hate to admit it but Effie
has never looked worse but on the bright
side
Haymitch has finally got his act
together number four there's a ton of
new kids on the block but do they have
the right stuff present on the coin of
the rebellion played by Julianne Moore
she's abandoned her beautiful ginger
locks for some weird skunk action Boggs
played by Maher shala Ali of house of
cards is one of the few people Katniss
will trust in d13
Cressida played by Margaery Tyrell I
mean Natalie Dormer winter is definitely
coming for her again her crew cast her
paws in masala film Katniss's actions
against the Capitol for propaganda we
all fled on our own
for this for you and the fifth and final
thing to know before scene Mockingjay is
wait what exactly is a Mockingjay Oh a
freaky hybrid of a mockingbird in at
Jabar J it can mimic human voices and
was created by the Capitol to listen in
on the rebels it's now become the symbol
of the new rebellion as a giant middle
finger to the Capitol boom from its
humble beginnings as a pin given from
one scissor to another to an elaborate
costume that gets Lenny Kravitz killed
it's clearly made its mark
Katniss isn't thrilled to be the
Mockingjay but she'll do whatever it
takes to keep her sister safe and to get
one of her loves back because in the end
it's all about prim prim prim prim and
Peeta's breads day and those are our 5
things to know before seeing Mockingjay
part 1 and don't forget to check out our
awesome Hunger Games character guide by
clicking here from Pentangle movie clips
I'm Meg McCarthy thanks for watching
don't forget to subscribe and remember
may the odds be ever in your favor
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]